I did a little road trip this weekend
with my nanny Todd Chrisley gets a
family reunion Behind Bars this is a
close family and they're obviously going
to spend time visiting with one another
ET confirms daughter Lindsay and his
mother Nanny Faye visited the reality
star just over a week after he and wife
Julie surrendered to prison caught
serving out a 12-year sentence for bank
fraud and tax evasion it just was not
the best week for me the emotions
associated with all of that and my
parents and my siblings and my
grandmother what we will not do is we
will not break opening up on her the
southern tea podcast Lindsay says she
and Nanny Faye took a drive over the
weekend I ended up taking a road trip
with Nanny and we only got two hours
away because she was convinced that she
was gonna do like all of this driving
and if you've ever ridden with someone
who's elderly who like probably
shouldn't have their license there's
nothing more nerve-wracking and you just
truly just want to take the wheel yeah
Nanny phase driving abilities were
featured plenty on Chrisley Knows Best
hey what you doing I see you and my eyes
is on YouTube they should be on the road
bye did you see that she just flipped me
off so when we stopped for our first
meal I got behind the wheel I was like
that's it Lindsay says she's also ready
to leave 2022 in the rear view mirror my
family struggled through a lot with my
parents this year there was just like so
many things that happened legally and
although the outcome was not what we
wanted there is some sense of peace and
closure and now we have the opportunity
to be able to adjust look any family who
faces a loved one going to prison
um it's a very difficult challenge
that's true for this family but they're
strong they're faithful and I think
they'll continue in in that Way Forward
Todd support from Lindsay comes after
the two reconnected following a bitter
Feud there will never be a
Reconciliation there was just some kind
of emotional
battle that Lindsay has had within
herself they patch things up in the wake
of the convictions the past few months
have been extremely hard for me and my
family I'm absolutely heartbroken and
devastated if Todd and Julie could share
a message with the world what do you
think they'd want them to know you know
I think they'd want folks to know that
they are the same people they've always
been that they didn't do these things
and they're going to fight to get their
name cleared and now Todd and wife Julie
plead their innocence while incarcerated
they'll file an appeal ahead of the
February 22nd deadline the reality of it
for me is that when you know you did not
do these things and yet you sit you
stand here convicted that's that's a
hard pill to swallow I think they're
optimistic and let me be clear I think
that optimism is well placed this trial
was riddled with heirs and we expect the
appeals court to see that
foreign